5 13 into friday morning what's cool at
school a youngster driven project that
helps our military families sleep better
at night well when an elementary school
in north las vegas just a hop skip and a
jump away from nellis air force base you
can bet they've got plenty of students
with parents or even siblings who are
serving our nation
and thanks to an industrious teacher at
watson elementary some 50 of those kids
were all in
on operation pillowcase
jodie cervanic operation pillowcase is
really a morale building um opportunity
where our students were able to decorate
a pillowcase with either their parent or
their siblings photo on it thanks to a
wonderful contributions from not only
local nevadans but outside of the state
we were able to get our donors choose
project funded which supplied the
pillowcases the iron on transfers the
stencils the fabric markers so it's a
great time for our kids to come together
realize that there's other kids at the
school that are just like them
of course we ended our pillowcase party
with some pizza and some cookies
all right way to go mr vanick and the
watson wranglers now as if operation
pillowcase wasn't enough they're now
gearing up for valentine's for veterans
they're collecting valentine's care
package snacks to send to service men
and women overseas if you'd like to help
with that we've got a link in the online
version of this story on eight newsnow
dot com and if you know something that's
cool at school let us know
just go to the cool at school tab under
the community tab on our
eightnewsnow.com website emailworks2
cool at school at 8newsnow.com so how
cool is decorating pillowcases oh great
that's awesome it's so simple but so
great yeah
it's creative and it just sends a great
message that they can sleep on
absolutely that's a family thing
and some of them have siblings who are
serving in the military these youngsters
in the elementary school that's awesome
thanks mr brown that is incredible
age difference
wow okay wow good stuff